la parole est à notre collègue madame
agnès canayer pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
depuis plusieurs mois nous assistons au
drame du camp de calais où plus de 6000
migrants compte désormais aux abords de
la ville notre collègue natacha bouchart
maire de calais ce débat courageusement
et tire la sonnette d'alarmé
régulièrement aujourd'hui l'état a
décidé de répartir une partie de ces
migrants dans des lieux d'hébergement
dispersées sur tout le territoire
français
en septembre dernier un véritable élan
de solidarité s'était manifesté
suite aux images terribles de famille
syrienne fuyant les combats lors de la
réunion des élus locaux le 12 septembre
dernier vous étiez engagé monsieur le
ministre à soutenir les communes
volontaires pour garantir de bonnes
conditions d'accueil de ces populations
à peine six semaines plus tard c'est au
mieux par un appel téléphonique
lapidaire du préfet ou par simple voie
de presse que les maires apprennent
l'arrivée imminente d'un groupe de
réfugiés de calais
la mobilisation des maires a démontré
qu'ils étaient prêts à coopérer mais
encore faut-il que l'état soit loyale et
les informent clairement sur la
situation des personnes déplacées
monsieur le ministre masse la question
sera simple comment comptez vous
associez véritablement les maires
concernés afin de faire en sorte que
tout ne se passe pas dans leur dos
comment un moment où les contraintes
financières sont de plus en plus lourdes
pour les communes et les dépenses
induites explose
allez-vous soutenir financièrement les
communes qui accueillent les migrants
mais aussi la parole et que monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur merci merci beaucoup madame
la sénatrice pour cette question qui
contribue à rétablir un certain nombre
de vérités sur ce qu'est l'action du
gouvernement notamment à calais puisque
j'ai entendu ce week-end que nous
concentrions volontairement les migrants
à calais pour faire monter le front
national vous venez de reconnaître que
nous les en demande au contraire de
quitter calais pour les répartir sur le
territoire national et c'est une oeuvre
de vie
et qu'il était utile de faire face un
certain nombre d'outrance que j'ai pu
entendre ce week-end et qui témoignaient
d'une véritable irresponsabilité de la
part de ceux qui ont tenu ces propos
vous me posez une question précise sur
deux sujets d'abord est-ce que c'est sur
la base du volontariat des mères que ce
fait cette répartition
j'ai donné des instructions extrêmement
clair aux préfets de région et
l'ensemble des maires sont préalablement
contacté par les préfets de région et
c'est sur la base du volontariat que ces
répartitions se font et je tiens
d'ailleurs devant le sénat qui est une
assemblée qui n'est pas une assemblée
comme les autres à remercier très
sincèrement l'ensemble des maires qui
sont loin des outrances qui sont loin
des amalgames qui sont dans la
responsabilité qu'ils ont conscience de
ce qu'est la dimension particulière de
cette crise migratoire et qui accepte en
très étroite liaison avec l'état
d'accueillir ces migrants l'état fournit
sans l'accompagnement social de manière
à ce qu'ils puissent être accueillis
dans les meilleures conditions vous
m'indiquer ensuite calé l'aide de l'état
je me répond de façon très précise
dès lors que l'état assure la totalité
des financements de l'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile puisque c'est lui qui
financent près de 28000 places en cada
qui seront créés pendant le quinquennat
c'est lui qui finance la mise en place
de l'hébergement d'urgence il a décidé
d'octroyer aux collectivités locales qui
acceptent de mettre des logements
disposition 1000 euros par migrants
accueilli un fonds de 50 millions
d'euros qui a été débloquée pour
accompagner la rénovation de logements
en coeur de bourg et nous mettons ces
dispositions en place pour toutes les
communes qui sont dans l'accueil
républicain de ces migrants et je veux
encore une fois leur adresser mes
remerciements les plus sincères
madame agnès canayer oui effectivement
il ya une volonté de collaborer affiché
en sept ans mais on voit qu'elle a quand
même du mal à irriguer sur l'ensemble
des territoires qui est un décalage
quand même entre la volonté ce que les
mères vivent au quotidien
car l'accueil des migrants c'est pas
simplement d émergence d hébergement
c'est aussi les accompagner dans les
actions sociales au quotidien le maire
qui est garant d'ordre public se
retrouve aujourd'hui quand même bien
seul pour gérer au quotidien ces
problèmes qui relèvent avant tout de la
compétence de l'étang merci monsieur
recoller